okay um good evening everybody and
welcome to this evening's meeting of
planning and development management
committee just by way of introduction my
name's aiden williams and i'm the chair
of the committee also present this
evening at the committee vice chair
councillor ben hartley
officers from the council's planning
service legal and democratic services
local highway authority as well as the
elected councillors who make up voting
members of the committee
and before we continue i'll just advise
for everyone's attention that this
meeting has been live streamed and
recorded
as this is a reconvened meeting from
last week we'll just proceed straight to
um
obviously note apologies from those who
can't join us this evening we've
accepted apologies from councillors
akanola chalkin diagonal and win stanley
and now if we move to agenda item six
and continue um applications for
permission to develop
the remaining application on the running
order is
106.535 which is sale high school in
sale um before we turn to the discussion
the item's going to be introduced by ms
milner
this application relates to
sale high school and the installation of
two air source heat pumps at the rear of
the king block building which forms part
of the high school
buildings as highlighted in red on your
screen the application has been reported
to planning committee because the
council is the applicant and objections
have been received
the proposed heat pumps and associated
enclosure would be sited on the south
side of the king block which is a
two-story block immediately to the north
of the playing fields the air source
heat pumps would be contained within a
timber enclosure which have a height of
one meter
project by 1.6 meters and width for two
points 2.6 meters letters of
representation have been received from
three local residents raising concerns
about noise from the air source heat
pumps colleagues in environmental health
have been consulted and raised no
objection on noise grounds subjects
subject to the conditions as outlined in
your report
therefore it's considered that the
proposal would be otherwise acceptable
and is recommended for approval
thank you um mrs munner there's nobody
registered to speak to this items have
any members happy to open the discussion
councillor morgan
thanks chair um i think we've had a few
of these recently and um in terms of the
issues i think we've discussed
length about the fact that some of the
the the fears aren't um aren't um
justified in terms of the comments that
have been raised so i'm i'm proposing we
accept officer recommendations uh um to
approve thank you
thank you um councillor welton
yeah i'm happy to second this proposal
um i think that the conditions are
sufficient to should be sufficient to
overcome the concerns that have been
raised thank you
thank you
many other members wishing to contribute
to the discussion
given we've had a counsellor hunting
thank you chairman um i think as we
discussed last time i made my sort of
things without any strong objections to
the pumps because they're less intrusive
than than other matters it's a nice bit
of virtue signaling it'll make very
little difference too very much but it's
no real reason under planning to refuse
it i don't think the noise issue is
going to be as harmful as this made out
given the
uh baffling of surrounding it but um as
i said it's the reasons there may be
non-planning reasons to object but uh on
that basis i'll be going along with it
but uh i don't hold on much hope for it
making a world of difference
okay thank you
um there has been a motion proposed and
seconded that this application be
granted permission in line with officer
recommendation
can't see anybody else indicating that
they'd like to contribute so we'll move
to the vote with members who are happy
to support that merchant can indicate
now please
okay i'm make that a unanimous decision
so
application is approved um we're now
turned to agenda item seven which is
urgent business i've received a separate
urgent business report relating to
um application 105 847 herron hounds in
template
this is not
an application that we're going to vote
for permission on but that will be
explained um in the introduction which
you're about to receive from ms milner
thank you chair
so this application
the application site is the existing
herring hounds hotel building garden
car park and located on the junction of
wood lane and shaftsbury avenue in
timperley the application proposed the
erection of 59 retirement apartments in
an l-shaped block
and fronting wood lane and shattesbury
avenue
along with nine retirement cottages to
the south of the site following the
demolition of the existing buildings on
site
an appeal has been lodged against
non-determination of the planning
application
this application is therefore brought to
committee for members to consider how
the application would have been
determined had they been able to do so
the pub has been identified as a
non-designated heritage asset by the
planning authority and the former
bowling green which is to the rear of
the site and currently forms part of the
pub garden
is designated as protected open space
both would be lost as a result of the
proposed development
letters of objection have been received
from 16 different addresses locally
the main concerns of residents being the
loss of the the pub
the scale and height of the proposal and
the proposed use
impacts on services infrastructure and
the highway network
a lack of parking and the environmental
impacts of the development
the main concerns of planning offices
relate to the loss of the pub as a
non-designated heritage asset but also
as a valued local community facility
the design and massing
of the
massive scale and appearance of the
proposed development the lack of amenity
space and the quality of the amenity
space that is provided for future
residents
of the development and a failure to
provide a development development plan
policy compliant level of affordable
housing
no ejection in principle is is raised to
retirement living accommodation but the
loss of the existing building and the
scale of the redevelopment are
considered inappropriate for this site
and as noted in the office report the
tilted balances engage having regard to
the council's lack of a five-year
housing supply however weighing the
benefits of the scheme against the harm
it is considered that the identified
harm arising from the proposal would
significantly and demonstrably outweigh
those benefits and therefore officers
are
um
putting this forward as a refusal
and for the reasons outlined in the
officer report i would just like to draw
your attention to the air that was
published last week and there has been
a couple of further amendments to this
but because the meeting has already been
opened we can't formally um
amend the published copy but just to
draw your attention in the air to
paragraph seven just to clarify a point
that although local plan policy l1
is out of date this does not render the
entire local plan out to date
i'd also like to draw your attention to
paragraph 33
and this is for the avoidance of doubt
um in regards to
the total loss of the pub on site and
the heritage and community benefits
benefits this facility brings and i
think the reading of the sentence could
have sounded like that the benefits
would be brought from its loss it's not
its loss it's the benefits of it being
there
and we've also amended um
reason for refusal
one this was due to a typing error to
refer to l2 l7 rather than l2
and we've updated our reason for refusal
three and four reason three would with
regards to the design and scale of the
proposal and reason four is regards to
the amenities based provision i'd also
like to draw your attention to the fact
that following further discussion with
colleagues in environmental health we
have withdrawn reason for refusal 6
which relates to noise
i can read out the revised reasons for
refusal in regards to design and amenity
space
so in regards to design reason for
reviews of three
we've now proposed that it states the
proposed development by virtue of its
design scale height massing sighting and
layout would result in a building which
would be seriously detrimental to and
out keeping with the character of the
area
as such the proposal does not represent
good design and is contrary to policy l7
of the traffic core strategy
the mppf and the ndg which is the
national design guide
and reason for refusal four
the proposed development fails to
provide a good standard of external
amenity space for future residents by
reason of its quantity and quality given
the scale and sighting of the amenity
space by virtue of its proximity to wood
lane
and shaftesbury avenue and the proposed
on-site car parking as such
the proposed contrary to policy l7 of
the core strategy and mppf thank you
chair
thank you
are there any members who'd like to open
the discussion on this item
counselor thomas
thank you chair uh i must concur
completely
with with what's just been said
it is
the scale of the development on the site
that has been proposed
would
dramatically and massively change
the environment
of the village
um
it's just inappropriate for where it has
been and any parking issues would
be created there's nothing nowhere in
the locality to
to accept or to to bear
additional parking so i must say i i
fully agree with the
recommendation within it and
i'm happy to propose that we accept that
thank you um councillor minis
thank you chair i similarly agree
entirely the building's also quite
iconic when you go down
um shasta avenue um and it i think it's
just
you know
the the what what's proposed to to
replace it is
you know is large
and
i think you know but whilst the site is
quite the site is the plot is quite
large i think that the loss i might make
a huge issue is loss of the of the
building i mean whether the building
gets changed into something else and
isn't a pub anymore that's different
matter but i think to lose the building
altogether i don't think would be an
acceptable um thing to do and the
building has been is in isn't exactly in
a dire state of where one that thinks
that it would be better off being
removed so i think that it's continued
to be to function as it has done for
many years and i'd like it to you know
be able to be kept
um as it is thank you so i'll be a
second um
did you propose to refuse i'll hopefully
um support us
i'll second that sorry to refuse the
application thank you
thank you and councilman morgan
thank you chair um
this uh the the pub actually though it's
not in my um not in my ward um just
slightly further down on wood lane at
the bend um um is the the
boundary between my ward along with
ultraman ward and village ward and so i
know that i know the location very well
um i i think it'd be really sad to lose
the pub um um you know i've acquainted
it yeah in terms of in the past
um but that isn't the main reason that i
kind of support the officer
recommendations to refuse it's
i mean the scale of a four-story
building
um this
i mean chassborough avenue is a it's a
it's a it's very wide road um you know
this is the the fault stories about it
being a a um uh airfield but it's a it's
a road of bungalows and semi-detached um
houses that it would transform that
junction which is a it's not just a
prominent entrance for into altering
them it's also the road into into
timperley as well which is a village
it's not a city it's a village um
um so i'm staggered to see kind of that
someone will propose such a huge huge
building i also like to point out in
terms of the of wood lane itself
um it's it has got speed bumps along it
but it's still a really really busy road
and i get quite a lot of case work from
residents worried about the speed and
the volume of traffic along that um so
um i'm absolutely absolutely agree with
everything that council
thomas and councilman said and i support
officer recommendations to reviews thank
you
thank you and councillor hassan
thank you uh i'm quite happy to whatever
earlier my colleagues have said and free
sport because it will
have a very bad effects on the
undo extra stress on local amenities
gps and dentists and all the scenes so
it is a village as mike also said it is
not a it is not as
a big town center as it is a village so
i fully agree with my colleagues
whatever they have said thank you
thank you councillor punting
thank you chairman i agree with pretty
much everything that's been said so far
but one thing i want to focus on that
hasn't really been mentioned so far is
the actual design it's a
shockingly awful third rate thrown
together with no effort no thought
can't be bothered to do anything better
design um and i must admit
looking at the name of the applicant
this is not entirely surprising it's not
the first time that churchill have
brought to brought to us
a terrible design we've refused them in
the past and then they seem to
as if from nowhere come back with a much
better design as if they're trying to
see what they can get away with you know
if we put forward this really awful
design what will trafford say and then
you refuse it it's happened several
times i could go through various sites
and mention that churchill has brought
forward awful designs that we then
refused and then they've come back with
something else so it looks more like
barracks accommodation than anything
else um
it was this is a very prominent location
and the design will look appalling and
that combined with the size and scale of
it will just make it into a monstrosity
um
i agree with all the other reasons but
that for me is one of the prime reasons
it would just look
abhorrent where this design in this
location is completely unsuitable no
effort has gone into it whatsoever and i
agree with the other reasons for refusal
but i just wanted to emphasize that once
i mean there you are
look at that you know i mean that if a
picture says a thousand words well there
you are i mean just look at it you know
um so uh
surely they can do better and indeed
when we have refused them in the past
they have done better why they can't
come forward with the half decent design
the first time around instead of
bringing it going through this
mock process where there's a let's do
this no you can't okay how about
something worthwhile why can't we just
move to the you know half decent design
first time around it's very frustrating
chairman thank you
thanks uh councillor hartley
thank you chad i do think we need to
consider the application on its merits
uh regardless of the history of the of
the developer i know sites that have
been developed by churchill which uh
which are good which are good
accommodations so um but based on
the application that's before as i agree
with what's been said there are
clear reasons why we should be
minded to refuse if it was our decision
and i think a number of those reasons
on their own would be sufficient to
refuse um so against the bunsen
mentioned the design which is poor
uh it's you know the height of it the
massing of it it's not set back enough
from um certainly on wood lane um
particularly given the prominent site
it's not appropriate um i think that
will be a reason to refuse on its own
the uh lack of affordable housing
provision will be a reason to refuse on
its own i think um
it's clearly viable to provide
affordable housing and 45 to the
requirement and live off of none
um
and they opened a lack of open space as
well i think
yeah financial contributions been
calculated but i don't think they've
offered that and the noise has been
resolved i think now hasn't it
but it's regressible because there is a
need for accommodation for older people
and
flexible and adaptable accommodation for
older people
so i know in the in the uh additional
information report it it does say the
amended paragraph 3 does say
uh had it not been for the total loss of
the pub
on site and the heritage and community
benefits this spring's residential
development could have been acceptable
i mean it's not a it's not a protected
heritage asset it's non-designated and
although it does have community value i
you know i think the principle of
residential development and result of
development for older people
would be acceptable in principle but not
not this so
yeah it's disappointing given there is a
dire need for that sort of accommodation
that the uh the application doesn't
doesn't tick anywhere near enough of the
boxes for us to approve in my view thank
you
[Music]
thank you um any other members wishing
in fact i think almost everyone spoke um
the only thing i wanted to reflect on is
that um there's there is
remarkable similarities between the
objections that have been made by
members of the public and the reasons
for refusal and i think that's really
welcome in this instance and i i really
welcome the carefully considered
position that the planning department's
taken in respect of the pub being an
important community facility you see
that in paragraph 25 and that was one of
the concerns that was raised by members
of the public so i'm happy to support
the recommendation that's before us this
evening um it has been
emotion has been proposed and seconded
that
[Music]
we would be minded to refuse in the
event that the application was before
committee yes um
and that's in line with officer
recommendation so we'll we'll turn to
that vote now with members who are happy
to support that um
motion can indicate
okay i made that decision unanimous um
that concludes the urgent business that
has been
tabled for this meeting and
i don't think there's anything further
for us to discuss so with that we will
shut this meeting now we'll close the
meeting thank you everybody